this is Tim Ferriss author of the number  one bestseller the 4-hour workweek I'm  here in Bratislava Slovakia  enjoying a very sunny and nice day how  would you like to travel the world for  free with a personal assistant again for  free at your beck and call or perhaps  you'd like to receive world class  artwork or have lunch with Jerry Yang  the co-founder of Yahoo while you're  learning how to race racecars and fly  hot-air balloons or maybe just having a  private party on a warship for you and  your best friends all these things you  can do for free and all you have to do  is go to liberation org that's lit Li T  liberation org and become part the  largest online literacy campaign in  history that's all you need to do takes  a few minutes doesn't cost a thing and  you could set yourself up not only to  have experiences that money cannot buy  but also to change the world the process  so check it out liberation org